- Yar, after killing me, what did ye plan on doing next?
- You know you don’t have to lean into the whole pirate thing.
KENNY, ATTACK!
What the hell? You’re 43 years old.
- Ya best start believing in GOAT stories, Mr. Rodgers.
You’re in one.
See, it goes right through me, and that’s the result of a healthy, pliable life.
- I can’t believe Brady took down all three of us legends.
- Another uneventful season.
- Look, if you think that you can just waltz in...oh, OK, nevermind.
- YOU’LL ALWAYS REMEMBER THE DAY YOU ALMOST
CAUGHT PATTY MAHOMES!
- [Josh Allen:] Let’s go.
- No. I want it to hurt.
- [Travis Kelce:] He could never love me like a No. 1 receiver.
I’m just a lowly tight end…
Dang, Brady still has a cannon.
- ♪♪♪ There once was a team 'twas lost at sea ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Till there came a man named Tom Brady ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Ditched Winston, they began to win ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Throw less picks, Tom, throw. ♪♪♪
- [Together:] HOOAH!
♪♪♪ SOON! MAY THE BUCCANEERS WIN ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ TO REMIND OURSELVES OF JON GRUDEN ♪♪♪
♪♪♪  SIMMS, GARCIA AND JOSH FREEMAN ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ JUST LET US HAVE THIS ONE! ♪♪♪
- And you're sure young people like this?
- [Gronk:] SEA SHANTIES HOT NOW.
- You better not be messing with me.
I DO NOT WANT TO LOOK OLD—
- Who are you rooting for?
- Oh, I just watch for the commercials.
- Then welcome to Team State Farm.
- Argh, come on, that’s DPI.
- Parlay!
Ok, so I’m going with Evans under 60 yards and Godwin under 70.
- EXCUSE ME?!
- WHERE DO YOU GET OFF?
- WE’LL NEVER CATCH THEM!
THEIR PIRATE SHIP HAS A FOOTBALL FIELD!
- We named the monkey Gronk.
- Curse you, Tom. You'll never get away with going to a
team with an already great offense.
- Hahaha, I started this season on the Jets.
- It’s me, controversial third receiver…
Scotty Miller!
- Who the hell is that?
- Dude, you’re CLEARLY Julian Edelman in disguise.
- What? No! Why? Did Tom say something? AHH.
- DON’T CHASE US, OR I’LL THROW YE ALL IN RONALD JONES’ LOCKER.
- Sup.
- BIENIEMY’S IN CHARGE OF THE SHIP.
- F--king finally.
- If I win without Belichick, I'll be free of the curse of the system QB.
- Look, they gave me a sword!
- You!
- [Gronk:] ME?!
- Oh God, did I kill Patrick Mahomes?...I could probably get away with this.
- Don't you see?! I’M THE NEW MAIN FOOTBALL CHARACTER.
- THIS IS MY LEGACY!
- I’M ONLY 25!
- [Kelce:] They know there’s 52 other players on the team, right?
- Haha, 52.
- Wait, do you just think any number's funny?
- Wow, Tom, you made it without me.
I’m…actually so proud of you.
Come. Come here...son.
No, It’s safe. Let’s hug it out.